hey i'm robert pattinson and i'm going
to talk about some of my
iconic performances
harry potter and the goblet of fire
cedric giggery the head of the
hufflepuff clan and he's the
first um death in harry potter which is
my claim to fame
it was definitely my concept to jump out
of the tree like at the beginning of my
intro which i then kind of repeated
later on in twilight for some reason i
always have the suggestions to be like
why doesn't he disappear just like
jumping out of a tree
[Music]
this strapping young lad must be cedric
am i right sir
i'd sort of fallen into it i mean it was
so terrifying i remember the first scene
i ever shot on that was in the magical
maze at the end and i'd never done
anything with special effects and stunts
and it was a big deal at the time it
felt like very very intimidating i think
i'd read a book on method acting the
only thing i really got out of that was
just beating yourself up before every
single scene that was basically my only
concept of how to how to prepare for a
scene i was psyching myself up as if i
was getting into a fight or something
before these scenes and just screaming
into a pillow and like fighting punching
myself and like kind of ripping my
clothing and stuff but i had all these
prosthetic wounds on then all of the
prosthetics would melt off my face and
i'd have to have all my makeup done
again but i had no concept of how to
kind of get into a
psyched up physical state i remember
holding a wand and thinking that it felt
so dorky to hold it like a magic wand so
i'm holding it like a gun with two hands
thinking i'm in like a die-hard movie i
think i even have one eye closed when
i'm like looking down like it's got a
it's got a viewfinder i spent a lot of
time living off the harry potter money i
moved to an apartment in soho in london
i really thought i was gonna do music at
that point i don't know where i had the
kind of belief in that because there was
absolutely no one saying that there's a
kind of music career on the table but i
was doing a lot of gigs all the time i
was constantly doing open mics all the
time and then
i
ran out of money basically it was
definitely going the wrong direction in
terms of a career up until twilight
twilight
i'd started to develop the to develop
this absolute terror of auditions which
i'm sure a lot of actors have and i'd
kind of could be so enthusiastic about
something and then the day of the
audition just my confidence would just
entirely collapse the same thing
happened the morning of the twilight
audition i used to live on my agent's
couch at the time
in in her apartment
and uh she sent me the email exchange
i'm freaking out i don't want to go to
the audition anymore even underneath it
saying well uh
fine fine a valium in my in my bathroom
but i've never taken a valium before i
was i just remember just feeling so
glorious in the in the back of the taxi
with the window open and just being like
wow this is what i've been missing and
so i kind of i think i had this sort of
quite spacey detached
kind of thing in the audition which must
have kind of worked for the character
that's edward cohen i do think there's
something in that first movie you can
see that people do it like we're taking
it seriously and it kind of has this has
a it has a passion to it everything
about me invites you in
my voice my face even my smell you know
i was 21 and
kind of wanted to make it as arty as
possible and so i was kind of we had
this strange tension where the studio
was kind of a little bit scared to make
things a little bit too
emo and stuff and i thought that was the
only way to play it it just seems so
ridiculous talking about it now because
i was literally
in i i spent so much time just
infuriated like the whole i it's
definitely something about being 21 as
well because i was i can't believe like
the way i was acting is half the time
like when i think back on it the scene
when edward introduces bella to his
family the first time i remember that
being the day because my agent my
manager like came up as a surprise visit
and i was like oh hey and just thought
everything was fine and then at lunch
they were like okay so whatever you're
doing right now you need after lunch
just do the opposite or you'll be fired
by the end of the day
and i
was like
okay and so uh that was the only thing
that got me to sort of smile a little
bit
like my own personal
brand of heroine i also think that if i
tried to play it light-hearted the way i
would do it would end up looking so
wrong
like that i'd probably end up looking
even more like a psychopath
there was this big like tons of people
signing this petition to have me not
cast but nothing about my life really
changed until the weekend or maybe like
a week before the movie came out so when
the signatures came it just felt such an
abstract uh like i just didn't really
care and
i was very excited about doing the movie
but yeah then when it came out
it just changed everything so fast i
mean it was it was overnight
batman
that was
no hesitation yes even my agents and
stuff were just thought like oh this is
interesting i mean i thought you only
wanted to play like
just total freaks all the time like he
is a freak because it's another freak
you look for things that kind of scare
you look at things that feel incredibly
out of reach it's such the kind of the
jewel and the crown of characters you
know you really could be doing more for
this city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything it's just a totally
different vibe i mean it's sad it's
something which i always thought about
batman i thought it's really really sad
it's a tragedy that's one of the reasons
it feels kind of different because it's
kind of it's like it's year two we're
not going to do the origin story again
instead of him getting over his his
parents his parents dying at the
beginning and then just becoming batman
and save and gotham now he really hasn't
gotten over them at all and it's kind of
and i basically i'm playing with the
parents death
constantly through that the whole time
there's latest it's all about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will i
always like approaching the kind of
major character like that and if you
look at it very literally or
like in a from an emotional context
it does end up coming becoming
kind of something kind of strange and
and it's always kind of shocks you what
comes out of it i mean i didn't really
realize how how sad it would make me
feel there's something about his
relationship with selena kyle as well
and it's it's very present in the
graphic novels and i think a lot of
those
writers really touched on that there's
ways to reinterpret that character in an
infinite number of ways this is the
maybe ninth or tenth batman movie and it
does feel incredibly different it's
funny i was talking to other actors who
are in the movie and everyone else said
like no and even matt said like don't
watch the other ones don't watch any of
the other movies don't be thinking about
that kind of stuff too much but i was
like i've already seen all the other
movies and they're incredibly familiar
to me and i like all the other moves
it's not like you're trying to rescue
like a dead character i mean they're all
like really really good portrayals and i
kind of really watched a lot of them on
the
run up up to it to just see
where
where's a gap um and something that
hasn't really been explored yet but i
think it's also really fun as well doing
that because it's like every single
person who's played well it's a pretty
um heavyweight actor and they all had
great interpretations of it and and very
very different so it was fun watching
them all i definitely don't have a
favorite no no
i mean i think christian bale did like
just such a
i mean it's so kind of iconic like as
the voice that he was doing in it but
it's almost impossible to not to not do
that where were the other drugs going i
don't know i swear to god swear to me
it's really hard to get into a
artificially lower register i mean and
it was to and to do it a long time
because i mean there's a lot of scenes
in this as well where you're kind of
long dialogue scenes as batman which is
quite unique out of um
a lot of the other movies in the series
and trying to kind of stay
really really low
and
have kind of nuanced in the lines and
stuff i mean it's really hard it's
really really hard when that light hits
the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning i think i was
doing vocal exercises without actually
knowing their vocal exercises i think
your larynx or something just got
strengthened when i was i was doing the
movie
when i was doing
adr for it
i mean i couldn't even do the voice
again i mean i had to kind of it
completely
reverted back to normal who are you
under there
i'm vengeance there's a kind of
understanding which i think every actor
who goes into it there's some way of
playing batman that just feels right as
batman and like if you try and do
something too
different
it sometimes feels really off but it's
funny it's like as soon as you put on
the suit it sort of does something to
you you start behaving in this quite
particular way and it might be about the
kind of restriction and the movement and
stuff where there's definitely elements
of just the kind of um practical aspect
of it you want to be able to turn your
head
short made backing out of the driveway
easier you don't know how you're gonna
feel until you put on the suit and then
just because this suit was a little bit
more articulated because i done the
audition in i think it was george
clooney's one and it was
incredibly difficult to move in well i'm
totally over all right positively me too
definitely you had to choose the suit by
the size of your head and i think my my
head was about was the closest to
clooney's head was your head like locked
it's locked and you're boiling hot like
absolutely boiling if you have any
lights on you or you're just pouring
sweat
and then as i was doing that and you're
also doing an audition so i'm kind of
terrified anyway and people are saying
what can we do about this sweat i mean
you're thinking like if i don't stop
sweating i'm not gonna get the part and
so you're trying to you're trying to
shut down your body a little bit if i'm
not mistaken that's the one with the
nipples isn't it it is but then me i
keep getting confused with because i
think there might be two nipple suits
i think
i think one has just more one has more
prominent nipples i think on the val
kilmer suit as well there's i think
there's some nipples on that there might
be one nipple
[Music]
good time was uh another wonderful
experience and also
a totally unexpected reaction to it as
well i remember talking to josh and
bernie
at
some hotel in l.a
and i said i want to do whatever you
guys are doing next i want to do it and
i remember josh saying do you mean that
because i'll have a script in six weeks
and uh
and
and like we'll do it
and then the first iteration of good
time came after six weeks and it was
unbelievable i mean they're great
directors but i love the way they write
so much
excuse me you're peter yes i am we're in
the middle of saying hello nick what are
you doing we're in the middle of
something here
about the stuff in the pan and then
please how would you like it if i made
you cry how would you like that benny is
also just a phenomenal actor as well i
mean he just stayed in the characters
like all day and would kind of slightly
change his voice when he had to kind of
suggest something to josh it really felt
like a character talking benny would be
doing a scene with me he was also
operating the boom at the same time so
he's like holding he's holding the boom
between us it's definitely the
definition of run and gun filmmaking
nick come here
stay with me
where'd he go where are you did you get
the bank you're circling around i'm on
the corner i'm on the corner where you
dropped me off you're gonna get back
here right now i wasn't really like
trying to perfect an accent it's just
something that felt right it's just all
just trying to do everything in an
intuitive way and it's weird because
like even it does sound like a queen's
specific queen's accent but it's kind of
uh
it wasn't i wasn't really doing it in a
very
academic way it was much more just
like just feeling your way through it i
think well there's two lines it was
probably my two favorite lines i think
i've ever said in maybe which is the one
is uh when i was saying to talia don't
be confused it's just gonna make it
worse for me i don't know anyone else
apart from josh who would ever come up
with that line and then the line i'm
talking about the kind of metaphysical
connection with with taliram and at the
end of it just undercuts it saying like
all right i'm just going to take a [ __ ]
in that guy's house okay i'm going to go
and take a [ __ ] in that guy's house
i'm going to try the hospital again in a
minute
just wait here for me okay
it's just a very very specific feeling
which the only other person i've ever
seen in a script with is is the
lighthouse
with robert eggers
[Music]
the lighthouse i play a character called
thomas winslow
um
uh no that's not even his name
jesus [ __ ] christ
thomas howard
yeah he's a little bit confused about
his identity he's kind of he's a little
bit of a frame ephraim winslow and uh
thomas howard that's i loved the witch
um
uh robert's previous movie i really
wanted to find something with him i
thought he's a very very special
director i had such a good time on good
time and i wanted to swing wildly the
other direction but i wanted everything
to be strange and i kind of said to
robert i only want to do strange things
and robert came back with the lighthouse
and said
if this isn't strange enough for you
then um
i don't think i'm capable of anything
stranger than this
[Music]
really trying to convince everyone that
the lighthouse was a comedy and trying
to convince i think it was the got the
the hfpa they can really trying to try
to convince like
relatively elderly people no it is a
comedy it's it's 100 comedy it should
qualify for the musical or comedy
section and everyone had watched this
incredibly dark movie and thinking like
ah i don't know how much for comedy it
is but then i see that audience is
watching it and
and people do like people laugh so much
more than i ever would have thought i
mean i thought it was hilarious when i
read the script but yeah i'm always
quite stunned about the the reaction to
it and also how much people like sea
shanties i mean i'd like that as i had
absolutely no idea i remember seeing the
first screening and everyone's like
bobbing their heads like they're at a
concert whenever a sea shanty came on
i'm like wow like how did eggers
know that that was going to be a trend
in 2018 i mean it's like that is out of
the blue
and it's funny because everyone's like
oh what accent are you doing blah blah i
always get these strange unfounded
criticisms about my accents but there's
this area in maine which i guess of how
the immigration worked there
it was a kind of a like devon or dorset
accents in england and then mixed with a
bit of
like certain types of american accents
and then there was like kind of weird
elements of like liverpudlian all i
guess all the different sailors that
have come there but you kind of listen
to this really tiny area in maine
and it's been the same accident for
hundreds of years and it doesn't sound
anything like a normal
um american accent but it's very very
fun it's also very addictive to do a lot
of this
a lot of the crew started uh speaking to
me like thanky and like all these
different things i don't have to say
nothing daddy
that neptune stretchy dead wind slow
oh
again when i asked him how the movie was
um
[Music]
he
he said like well
it's basically willem going
and you're going like
and i'm like okay it sounds sounds great
only when he
crowned in cockle shells his coral time
trident screeches banshee-like in the
tempest
and plunges right through your garlic it
was absolutely great working with one we
rehearsed uh for about a week before we
started shooting and he has
so much energy
it's just unreal it's like almost like
working with like a six-year-old like
this have kind of
there's nothing that fatigues him and uh
and so i was kind of a little bit
terrified because he would literally
we'd
rehearse the entire movie
and then the second we got to the end
he's like
again
not just start doing it again and and he
hasn't his energy hadn't even been
dented he's the best
what
what
the scene where we're saying what to
each other just going what what what
what what i just remember seeing that in
the script it was over three pages where
everyone's lying was just it was just
saying what what what what what what and
you're looking at going like this can't
be
actually in a script it's one of those
things where you go
i'm not going to see this again ever in
my entire life and i want to be the
person to say this because i'll be
really really annoyed if someone else
gets to do it
what what what what what what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the most apocalyptic spy movie
that's ever been made they're really
really big concepts but it's kind of
it's it's like all the christmas movies
you can kind of interpret them you can
either like really really dig into it
and find so many different threads to to
pull all you can kind of appreciate it's
like a big
massive adventure action movie and you
don't really need to know what's
happening like that much
[Music]
it's so complicated to make the story
work you just thought this this is it's
so insane this is even happening i mean
we're in
estonia they've made a car where they've
switched the the engine rather there's a
driver driving it with the back wheels
at the front for him and me and john
david are pretending to drive it
backwards but with about
700
cars all driving in reverse around us i
mean it was like one of the most
exciting theme park rides you've ever
been on in your life and then you're
trying to trying to do a uh
a scene at the same time i mean it was
i i don't think they're gonna be making
movies like that ever again
[Music]
cosmopolis
any special reason we're in the car
instead of the office
what makes you think we're in the car
instead of the office cosmopolis is
about a
uh 28 year old asset manager called eric
packer he gets a kind of obscure death
threat and
he starts to kind of intentionally
unravel his own life i remember doing it
and thinking the audience i want for
this is for someone in 10 years time to
be watching tv at three o'clock in the
morning and this comes on and then you
have no idea if you're asleep or not
this is loss of faith it will force the
orange drop dollar will settle up the
yuan will drop where's chin
working on visual patterns we were
shooting inside a limo that was the same
size as a normal limo it was kind of and
the cameras on the techno cranes i've
never done a movie like it where you
just you're doing the time movie inside
like um
a kind of vocal recording booth almost
like it was very very strange and it
just got to the point by the end of the
shoot i never even left the limo i just
stayed in it all day i love that movie
i've seen it so many times and i think
it's really
i think it's one of my favorite things
i've ever done
[Music]
break the laws of nature
you'll pay for it
[Music]
claire denim who directed that is just
one of my favorite people in the entire
world if anyone can experience what it's
like to do a clergy movie i would
definitely say you've got you have to do
it but it's completely different to
anything else you just suddenly realize
you can you can approach filmmaking and
acting in in
totally different ways every single
movie um and directors like that really
allow you the freedom to do it
hmm it's the first strawberry
so fun i mean with my friend's kid um
it's my god daughter we'd cast because
they normally cast identical twin babies
for that kind of situation and uh and
the night before the shoot started i
went to meet the babies and the babies
wouldn't have anything to do with me at
all and would just scream whenever i
came anywhere near them and i tried to
kind of bond with them for about four
hours and it was just nothing but terror
coming out of them and it was supposed
to be this kind of like you know quite
sweet relationship they had with my
daughter in it and i got my friend sam
and i was like what are you doing for
the next two weeks like can a scarlet
just play my daughter in a movie and
they flew out the next morning and
and i think i'd only ever met scarlett
like once or twice when she was a young
young baby but
it worked out perfectly my old man could
see me now
break the laws of nature
you'll pay for it
gq
this
is my fortress of
solitude anonymous couch anonymous room
anonymous hotel
a quadrant of trolls
[Music]
[Laughter]
classic performances
i love that thing i think it's really
funny
that's like i think that was the entire
thing from conception
to completion was about an hour and a
half
like just uh
uh or maybe maybe two hours at the max
remember my manager saying after that
you should do a tv series of this i'm
like of what
there is
like so you want me to end my career
um but yeah it's really fun i know what
i should do to promote this movie just
do a thing about
eating a hot dog
and losing your mind you can call me
wrong i eat hot dogs
[Music]
the rover
what you doing with this car
it's my brother's car
there's your brother
[Music]
where is he it's funny with acting stuff
the director who just sees something new
that you don't really know you have and
kind of shows
trust and belief in you and you can take
a risk and it just um and people trust
you for a bit and it just it felt like a
very important move just like really
just
sort of sink into a character it really
felt like that i could stay in it all
day like i really really felt there's
something about the environment of where
we're shooting at the outback it just
felt like there was almost no sign of a
film crew anywhere i mean it was just
one of the most immersive experiences
also beautifully written as well i can't
tell you nothing more in order to tell
you
don't you think you've already told me
start [ __ ] talking to me
the fact that i'm still getting jobs
like
that's just kind of blows my mind like
every every single day i don't quite
understand i think i by accident sold my
soul but i get so excited about it
there's not even a single element of me
which is like jaded about it at all it's
a great thing about acting as a job as
well but you always think there is all
the insecurity about not having you know
being unemployed like 90 of the time but
it has the potential to completely
change your life like every single time
it's very exciting no matter how small
the movie is i mean it can kind of you
can have this kind it can be a certain
kind of explosion in your reality